You're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than itself. There's been
a change in the image of thought. That's what it is, that's what it is, the internal structure of
but as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from the subject.
So this is the first day we're doing book four of The Gay Science, Saint Januarius, and um, I'm Nathaniel
Street at Mount Saint Vincent University, and I'm joined by Nate DeProspo at Oberland College, and
John Muckelbauer at University of South Carolina. And John, it kind of makes sense to start with you
on this one, I think, just because this isn't just your favorite book, but it's your favorite
favorite part chapter, favorite, yeah, favorite part of your favorite book, and I mean, I don't know, maybe
it'd be worth just starting off, like, you talking a little bit about why or how that came to be or what
you, what you find in turning to this book. I just love that that first aphorism for me is just like
that's the kind of thing that I need to read uh when I'm having a bad, you know, week or month or
whatever. The the thing that interests me so much about this, this book, um, the conjunction between
affirmation and later he'll call it criticism. Um, I don't know that he uses the word negation. He might
use the word negation, nay saying, contradiction, nay saying, contradiction. He does, yeah, right, yeah. Um,
that's what's always interested me, right? Like what's always interested me about Nietzsche is this, like,
I want to be this yes sayer, I want to be this affirmative, I want to make the world beautiful
interpreting it as beautiful, and then he turned the page and he's like, and here's another thing that
sucks, and here's, and here's a dumb ass for being like that, and there's a dumb ass, right? In other
words, the tone of the staffers and doesn't sound like a lot of things yet. Are you talking about 276
for the new year, or are you talking about the little prelude for the for the new year?
You know, um, so for the new year, I'm still alive. I still think I must still be alive because I still
have to think sum ergo cogito cogito ergo sum. Today everyone allows himself to express his dearest wish
and thoughts. So I too want to say that I wish for my from myself today, and what thought first crossed my
heart, what thought shall be the reason, warrant, and sweetness of the rest of my life? I want to learn
more and more how to see what is necessary in things as what is beautiful in them. Thus I will be one of
those who make things beautiful and more fati let that be my love from now on. I do not want to wage war
against ugliness. I do not want to accuse. I do not even want to accuse the accusers. Let looking away be
my only negation, and all in all, and on the whole someday I want to only be a yes sayer. It's all right
like to see as beautiful what is necessary, and you know, to to see what's necessary things as a as
beautiful, and that's how you make things beautiful, you know, um, and uh, you know, I don't want to accuse
I don't even want to accuse those she's accused, and then you just like turn a few pages later and it's
just like, and here's another dumbass, and here's another dumb, you know, the the sort of or if we
want to take this sort of more uh, I guess sort of philosophical, the the one on criticism in 307
so this is, this is so 307 in favor of criticism. Now something that you formerly loved as truth as a
truth or probability strikes you as an error. You shed it and fancy that this represents a victory
for your reason, but perhaps this error was as necessary. Here's the word for you then when you
were still a different person, you were always a different person, as are all your present truths
being a skin as it were that concealed and covered a great deal that you are not yet permitted to see.
What killed that opinion for you was your new life and not your reason. You no longer need it
and now it collapses and the unreason crawls out of it into the light like a worm. When we criticize
something there this is no arbitrary and impersonal event, it is at least very often evidence of vital
energies in us that are growing and shedding a skin. We negate and must negate because something in us
wants to live and affirm something that we perhaps do not know or see as yet. This is said in favor of
criticism. And and of course so Kaufman's note there uh, which you probably don't have, Nathaniel, is um,
um, but I I knew that that boo boo would like this. It might be interesting to compare this section
with Hegel's Phenomenology of Spirit.
The most obvious reference, that's hilarious, right, right? Um, wait, sorry, which one is this? So that's three
that's three oh seven. Okay, so so again he begins by saying I don't want to accuse the accusers I don't
you know, I I want to see uh what is beautiful uh, I want to see what is necessary and things as
beautiful and thereby make them beautiful. But here's one of the things that are necessary
Negation criticism right as a symptom of a way of life right so that so when I mean I think it's really
important that he says he doesn't say I am a yes-sayer I am affirmative right it's like I want to
head that way right like I I want to point in that direction right so it's so looking away shall be my
only negation and all in all and on the whole someday I wish to be only a yes-sayer right and there's the
constant notion of the preparatory human beings right like the there's that that wonderful uh one on like
we're living in an age now where we're like you know I welcome all signs of a more warlike age or whatever
because not because they're gonna win in fact quite the opposite better because they're going to lose
right because they're going to die and create possibilities for for something else right so it and that's
where it gets that's where you get messy in an interesting way for me right so it doesn't
simply become affirmation you know over here there's affirmation and over here there's negation it's like
no one of the things that's necessary is like right that kind of relentless criticism the accusing of the
of the accusers and it's just a matter of how one does it right it's not a matter of whether or not
one is negative or not negative it's the style of those negations it's a style of negation
Deleuze says Deleuze says a similar thing in in Dialogues where he's he's like you don't I'm not
just trying to get rid of dualisms you know like that's not the point of this that the point is
mobilizing dualisms in a certain direction so that they're not a function of a hierarchy that's right
right so that they they do something different yeah that's their line in A Thousand Plateaus is we
we um create uh dualisms and deploy them against other dualisms or we create dualisms to destroy
other dualisms right moving the for moving the furniture and that that's all I mean that that's
the project and you have to me you have everything here right like in other words reason like in that
in that aphorism that I just read the 307 reason is a symptom of a way of life that's it right like
it's not your reasons that object to this thing it's that the the person who you are now doesn't
need that belief uh the person that you were previously did so that's that sense in which like
and you see it clearly in Zarathustra and this is heading towards Zarathustra it's like
the the ultimate eternal return test is the affirmation of everything right even the bad
stuff right or quote-unquote bad stuff right even the the horrific stuff I mean that's the thing like
Zarathustra chokes on the black snake of resentment um because he can't get over you know saying like God
suffering is horrible and there's a lot of people who really suffer and it's a shitty thing it's like
well the existence of that shittiness is a counter argument against life that has to get overcome
you know because because obviously the goal here there's another one that other passage sorry I know
I'm jumping around a lot but there's that other passage in there about um debt the the death versus
life right like it's the um that I'm not too 78 this is the thought of death yeah right like it's it makes
me happy that men do not want I mean and look it's this great it's that great sort of company think
think about because here's the thing you think Nietzsche would say or I would you would one would think
that Nietzsche would say is like relentless honesty in the face of one's death is necessary right like you
have to like look that's more like Heidegger right that is more like Heidegger that's absolutely the
authentic being and he's like no not at all it's totally great that we lie to ourselves and that
we don't ever face death like that yeah what a force of will or life I mean like given how present
death ought to be given how like necessary it is it is mind-blowing that it isn't you know perpetually
always you know pressing on us and yet we're like these fucking awesome critters that are able to
create these you know yeah delusions and fantasies that make life really worth living what what's what's
nice is that it's not pathologized in the same way that it would be for Freud or Lacan like with the
death drive right where it's like it's all it's only framed not just structurally negatively but
qualitatively like this is a existential negative phenomenon whereas for Nietzsche it's it's framed
and I'm with a much different tonality towards the problem definitely and it's and and Kaufman has
another uh a note there that's worth pointing out he's like here's why Nietzsche is not an existentialist
guys right like it's straightforwardly so this isn't like you know staring one's death in the face is
the only way you know to sort of to truly live you know and uh and I I mean I you know that that is
it makes me happy that men do not want at all to think the thought of death I should like very much to
do something that would make the thought of life even a hundred times more appealing to them you know
So this it's and that to me that is the refrain I mean when when you think about it a little further
you're like that is Nietzsche right like his whole beef with transcendence is what it is the denigration
of life right like what it does by projecting another world that sees this one as a sort of
failed version thereof like that's the the stabilizing function of that right right and it's
the moralization and all of those things are because they devalue and denigrate in the name of
something higher right life well these passages are they're they're all so interwoven I mean the the
one that you just gave on on death and that desire to um to to find ways to to find ways of producing
and and delighting in life look at 289 and to get on the ships and he describes the sort of the the
production of a personal philosophy as the production of one's own uh sun warming blessing impregnating
shining especially for him how it makes him independent of praise and blame and at the end
he's like the moral earth is too round the moral earth too has its antipodes the antipodes too have
their right to exist there is another world uh to discover and more than one onto the ships you
philosophers and there's like sort of to round out what you said about transcendence there's not just
there's there's his critique is of the other world that sets and corrects and forms this one and judges
this one but he moves to the pluralist positions like no there are as many worlds as we produce
yet to do right and this this I mean to go back to um 276 the the very first one for the new year
I'd love the inversion of the cogito Descartes cogito it's not yeah I you know I I think therefore I am
it was like I am therefore I have to think there's this there's this compulsion to this um this necessity of
but you you started this off with this question of um John of this interesting potentially paradoxical
um drive to uh affirm one's fate and then and to be the yes-sayer and then also um which then seems like
there's some will away from negation away from um what do you say I won't accuse the ugliness I don't
want to wage war against ugliness um which he doesn't wage war against ugly he kind of wages war against
the strongest right yeah and what I what I find here is really an ode to becoming
in in that um there in so far as there is conflict war negation um contradiction um criticism critique
it is sort of as as an expression of will of strength as a a delight in as in a delight of the fullness
of of life and including life's um a penchant for acting on other life or force acting on
on other force and not just a delight in the exertion of that will but a delight in the transformative
um aspect of that will as well which is why you know the thing that the truth that turns out to be
the heir or the former self that becomes the new self that's incredibly necessary to to exhaust oneself
to exhaust and and to i mean insofar as there's an existentialism here is one must die
you know multiple times a day one must constantly right constantly must be one must be sacrificing oneself
for the promise of of the new creation of the of the new self and not because there's not to redeem or to
save the new self but to birth it to constantly birth it yeah what I like also the the sense of just
the sense of optimism that's kind of attached to this project too like at the the the notion that um
philosophy actually has material effects in the world right it's not just this abstract like
masturbatory uh thing it's not the philosopher at least as far as I'm interpreting it's philosophy
which can kind of mean it can it can take many different sizes and all different kinds of right
as an activity or or force like you like you were saying um which I think is just an important
for me at least uh it would be easy to fall into the trap that everything's been said
everything interesting or everything compelling that's ever been said has been said and so what
are we how are we going to contribute to this to this conversation in a way that that actually has
an effect on other people um and Nietzsche's like I'm not like he's he's explicitly like this is not
the end point I which is kind of what Hegel does right Nietzsche's like no we this is in service of
further things right like it's a proposal but a furtherness without a destination a furtherness
without a better like that is I think that's really key because it's not I think it was really
important what you said that it's not the philosophers that are important they're not the
philosophers who like do all the heavy lifting and all the thinking and then tell us how it really
is and then we just sort of you know end the story there but it's the activity or the act of
of the philosophy itself which is which is production which is the the building of new styles of of life
hitherto unimaginable because you can only work with the raw material you have and that's where
We go back to that, the aphorism that I ended with last time, that when I cheated, you know, and jumped
forward to the 324 in here where, you know, no life has not disappointed me; on the contrary, I find it
truer, more desirable, and mysterious every year ever since the day when the great liberator came to me
the idea that life could be an experiment of the seeker for knowledge, not a duty, not a calamity, not
trickery, and knowledge itself let it be something else for others, a bed to rest on on the way to such
a bed, a diversion, a form of leisure. For me it is a world of dangers and victories in which heroic
feelings to find places to dance and play life as a means to knowledge with this principle in one's
heart one can live not only boldly but even gaily and laugh gaily too and who knows how to laugh anyway
and live well if he doesn't first know a good deal about war and victory, right? I mean that. That to me
it's like, yeah, this is the the sum ergo cogito, right? Like that, I, you know, thinking is an activity in
the world, you know, that that does something. I mean, it's it's it's very clear even in that first one
where he says, or that first aphorism, where I want to learn more and more to see as beautiful what is
necessary in things, then I shall be one of those who makes things beautiful, right? To see as in other
words the act of being able to perceive this thing or produce this thing as beautiful is what makes it
beautiful, yeah, right? Like that that also wedding, you know, beauty with necessity too. That's right. Seeing
the seeing the necessity as the beautiful, like that's the sort of affirmation, and you know, keep in mind
this book's going to end with the first, you know, eternal return, right? The uh the first sort of
proclamation of the eternal return. Like that's where this thinking of affirmation goes, you know
and then Zarathustra before you know book five, I think it too about the way that beauty artistic beauty
has such a um like the the commonplace turn toward is always as a redemptive act as a life material
life sucks make it pretty, right? Right? And this is such a different move. It's the exact opposite. It's like
nothing needs to be redeemed, nothing needs to be redeemed. Finding the necessity and that's the
beauty. That's right, that's right, that's right. Well there also is not, I mean, there's not, there isn't
really a material reality without the interpretive function, right? Of course, for Nietzsche, yeah, I mean
there's not distinct, there's not a separation or said more precisely the idea that there is a
separation is the product of an interpretation, right? Like in other words, that's one one form of life
that sees objects and interpretations as distinctive, um, as distinct things which is then always operating
within an economy where you know the material or life, yeah, that's second, that's a confluence or
constellation of interpretations or if it's right wills. That's right, right. That second just that's like
the diagnostic gesture which makes it something other than simply negation, right? It's not
Nietzsche's version of life or of perspective versus the traditional one. It's the traditional one is
incorporated us in the entire that's i i i learned that move honestly. I learned that move from Foucault
uh in History of Sexuality when he takes on psychoanalysis towards the end and what he shows is that
psychoanalysis is part of the deployment of sexuality and it was in other words insofar as that book is
targeted against psychoanalysis and Marxism they're two conceptions of power and what it does is it folds
those conceptions into its narrative rather than our it doesn't argue against them, right? It's not like
here, you know, my thing versus your thing. It's like no your thing is uh an element at a one expression
of this larger thing that is my thing. It's a totally different way of doing criticism, I think Derrida
I mean that's what Derrida does all the time. It's a totally different way of thinking of criticism
because it's not critical in the usual straightforward negative sense. It's appropriative as fuck, right? Like
it's not like it's nice and gentle either uh but that's that's the move that I always try to uh teach
uh like grad students. It's like learn how to argue in such a way that you don't argue against something
you know, and it's it's it's it's hard to do, right? Like it's it's it's not intuitively it's so much
easier if we could have an object that we're separated from that we can say here's why that's
bad. Like Palestinians bad Israelis good or vice versa, right? Like what uh, you know, it's so much easier
when we can do that um because we have a target and it's and we have a target from which we see
ourselves as entirely separated, right? And so we are not implicated in the dynamic and I think that's to me
the thing that Nietzsche is like no no no you your little style of life is always implicated in
everything you think, motherfucker, right? Like it just you are always at stake whether you want to see
yourself as such or not and in fact not being at stake would be the greatest harm the greatest
Nihilism, actually, yeah, to actually be able to remove oneself from that, from that economy, it always
baffles me how people sort of see Nietzsche as a nihilist, but I know it's like, it's, I feel like
yeah, Hegel's been the more of a nihilist, at least tonally, yeah, yeah, but this is what I find Nietzsche
doing over and over, especially in this book, is is taking a term and then subtly dividing it into
senses. So yeah, you know, negation isn't negation isn't negation, criticism isn't criticism isn't
criticism, knowledge, and think about how we like think about the deployment of knowledge
here as compared to other places in this book and say like especially yeah in our favorite essay and
On Truth and Lying in a Non-Moral Sense, is that that sort of like the hubris of knowledge and the
falseness of knowledge. And here's like, I mean, of knowledge. Like, we've been like, this is your time.
there we took generations of of um bad conscience and resentment to actually be able to move against the
and now like this is, you know, I he he declares his desire for a knowledge, yeah, and but it's a very like
but that he divides that term, and it's he does not desire the stability with which we tend to
associate knowledge, not scientific knowledge. It's not or or metaphysical or or eternal or transcendent
knowledge, like any basically, you know, truth in any way that we tend to think of it. It's not
the answer, and it is nothing more than sort of the again the sort of the man the manifestation or the
byproduct of a certain style of life, a sort of a kind of of a kind of criticism, a kind of skepticism, a kind
of of um nuance, cultivating a nuance of hearing and seeing and tasting that you know these that
produces the world around you. But they're not, they can't be, they can't be enduring habits. They have
to be brief habits, all right, right, I mean, now you guys see probably by this point and certainly with
this book, you know, this chunk of this book, like why this is like a self-help book for me, like why
why I have always used this as a sort of self-help book. I mean really it's like just okay, I I need these
reminders, I need these refreshers, I need to be I need to be put on that, you know, put on that path
you know, it's in unlike any other philosophy for me. I mean, it all of course is symptoms of various
kinds of things, but this is you guys know like the the book that I get like remember a couple years ago
and I was having things were going poorly or whatever, and I was just like I gotta I'm just
gonna read some Gay Science um and and that that this is what I go to, right? I go to book four
well, book three also I you know, but but book four especially. This is to me, yeah, it's great, like I
mean, yeah, um, for me it's it works. No, I like it too, I just wonder why I mean I I understand I guess
why it has a sort of therapeutic function for you, but I feel like for a lot of other thinkers maybe in a
that of a different style they wouldn't experience that same function from this text, right? Like a lot
of these things, right, like a lot of the things that he's trying to complicate, those styles of
thinking would be disoriented, yeah, and confused, and would react against this, right? So it's interesting
that I mean it's not that I mean they're different people are different, well, in the way like an
autoimmune system would want to shut down a virus, right? That's that's the sort of the reaction against
it, and and that, like this, I mean, you know, I I I also see the levity in this book, and John you've
prescribed this this book to me on more than one occasion, and at least for me what it what it does is it
takes the serious and it doesn't make it not serious. It doesn't make it it doesn't make the weight of
life um comedic, but it gives it it it creates um the possibility of a certain kind of delight
or or levity uh to it, you know, not because now it's become not important or not serious, but because
of it's it becomes a thing to be able to affirm. It becomes a a sort of a um a set of signs to
diagnose for a health of life. Like think about that. I mean seriously uh
all of the philosophy that we've read there is just a persistent tone of life as something that has
to be endured, you know, and and or survived, and that's just missing here, yeah, right? Like that's
that's to me what what's different, like, you know, what's different what what Nietzsche does is introduces
he would say something like introducing some fresh air into the history of philosophy, right? Where
it's it's just like there's no sense of endurance, there's no sense of like one has to figure out how
to live because life is is a struggle. It's like no man, this is well and arguably arguably his arguably his
life was the hardest, at least physically, yeah, yeah, and then the writing of this as well, this is like
when he's a sense of great health is the migraines are kicking his ass and yeah but you know he always
talked about it as his health even and Ecce Homo, right? Like this was my health, you know, he
talks about it as an yeah he talks about it as an opportunity to shift his styles of engagement like to
shift his habits like go get going from sick to healthy that changes your orientation towards the
world well 295 on on brief habits i love that too yeah that that you know he you know i love brief
habits and consider them invaluable means for getting to know many things and states down to the bottom
of their sweetness and bitterness my nature is designed entirely for brief habits even in the needs of
of its physical health and generally as far as i can see at all from the lowest to the highest and just
like the sense of fully committing oneself to to a set of habits to see what they produce and then at
a certain point in time and this this makes me think later down he says um and then one day it's time
is up the good thing parts for me and not something that now disgusts me but peacefully and sated with
me that reminds me of the earlier aphorism on friendship and the sort of the notion of
of intense important friendships as being potentially temporary coordinations that
end right they well they don't end but they they can do they you know they launch each other in
different directions they wouldn't have been launched in those directions right but but yeah like the the
you know the moment of that intimacy has passed and would be a strange fetishizing thing to try to
remake it or recover it so then at the end of this um 295 he sort of you know he juxtaposes the brief
habits against enduring habits um which you know terrify him uh i hate them and i feel as if a tyrant
has come near me in the air around me there's there's your atmospheric language john the air around me is
thickening when events take shape that seem inevitable to produce enduring habits so then you know he gets
toward the end and you know there's that you'd think maybe he's going to go completely in the other
direction and go to some sort of like a dream of Kairos and just be like i just pure improvisation and
he doesn't do that at all no to me the most intolerable the truly terrible would of course
be a life entirely without habits a life that continually demanded improvisation that would
be my exile in my Siberia and it makes me think you know in terms of this is Nietzsche's artistic
sensibility because it would be the erasure of any raw material from which to create brief habits
give you enough material and form and force to be able to create with them enduring habits make
everything too heavy around you you can't work with it but no habits at all there's nothing to work
with that's that's where if we in in in the truth and lies thing it's not go artistic man right like
who's constantly improvising if there is some sort of amalgam of rational man and artistic man but
artistic man has to constantly undo rational man and rational man has to constantly give
something to work with for de-territorialization and re-territorialization yeah exactly
but one of the functions i think that he emphasizes in this uh aphorism is that a brief habit carries
with it sort of the delusion that that it will be eternal yeah like and then you just have to break
from that right no no you have to go through it that because because it's of such an intense um
of such an intensity that because one isn't laying it down as a program one is inhabiting it affirming
oneself through it like this is the path and then it inevitably becomes something else
right it changed i mean it's just that's part of also just affirming fate or Amar Fati right i mean
i know this is not i'm gonna bring a kind of a silly example into this this is not exactly what
he means i'm sure but like um when i moved to Cleveland right it's a different climate there's
no disc golf right that was like a huge part of my life actually in Charlotte it was like my community
was all based around that all my friends i come to Cleveland no disc golf so you don't i don't at
least my tendency is not to perseverate on that and just be like why can't i have fucking disc golf
and just like get you just fill it with other shit i started cooking playing more basketball right
you find other things to latch on to right and this this is theoretically an external imposition onto
me right but you you have to treat it differently than that from that and in fact i think that's
exactly what he's talking about because when he's talking about yeah they're enduring habits is like
well how do enduring habits happen owing to an official position a constant association with
the same people a permanent domicile you know the best one or a uniquely good health good health
health constant good health in other words like you don't want to always be in any particular you
know like interact with different people i mean this is this is the kick in my that i always need
because you know how i'm always like i don't want any new experiences
So it's, yeah, it's helpful for me to get this kind of like, no, no, no, go just do something else.
Yes, at the very bottom of my soul, I am grateful to all of my misery and illness and whatever else is
imperfect than me because they provide a hundred back doors through which I can escape enduring
habits. Yeah, yeah, yeah, but I feel like he's not, he's also not buying into the cliche. I mean, maybe this
is more of a contemporary thing where it's like, you just need to change the content of the habit. I
feel like it's more of like shifting your style. Yeah, like you don't, you don't, when you move to another
country or another state, right, your problems carry with you. That's sort of the, you're not going to fix your
problems just by changing locations, right? So something else, you could just move from disc golf to some
other to hacky sack or whatever, you know, like they could replace and some other stoner sport.
That's exactly what I was, I wasn't thinking that consciously, but you're exactly right.
But yeah, and then that's that, you know? So so I think that you're right, there is a sort of dispositional
I mean, but but but it's also the importance of putting oneself in situations and circumstances
that are going to uh produce dispositional shifts, right? Like, I mean, that that it's not
it's not simply worse of my will to um, you know, to overcome my my habit here. You have to have a back
back door to go through. You have to have back doors, like you have to have these are back doors. These are
life circumstances, adverse life circumstances that are effectively back doors for getting out of your
life or for re-articulating or changing your disposition. Think how different this is though
because Nate, you made me think of contemporary thinking on habits and the sort of the way that
it's not the content so much as it is the form, like with smoking, right? You want to quit smoking? Well,
you can't just use force of will to get rid of it. You have to be able to find some other kind of habit
that's going to because you know like within the psychoanalytic realm the smoking is a um, a coping
mechanism for some sort of trigger in your life and that trigger is not going to go away or that source
that stress isn't going to go away, so you know what are you going to do? You're going to chew gum.
You're going to walk around the block. You're going to sort of replace the smoking habit with something
else that has the the same kind of um, uh, coping function to it. And this is just seems to be the
the form content distinction here just doesn't even seem to apply. It doesn't even really seem to make
sense what that would be because it's not looking at it's not fundamentally seeing a habit as a coping
mechanism for some sort of more like baseline issue that that the habit here is life producing rather
than life coping it is it is world creating so you know whatever whatever it is the move might
precipitate those back doors, go through one of those back doors, you you're killing yourself and
becoming something else. It's a transformative pathway. It's not a it's not an exchange. It doesn't operate
but you know to use the Delusian language it doesn't operate within an economy of generality of of um
of exchange and um equality. It happens within an economy of theft and gift only can be taken away and and
given. It does. It makes me think because Deleuze is uh interest in in um Hume is all around
habit, like the the notion of habit. It makes me think of the different ways of thinking habit and
when I do that with Deleuze I always for me return to the refrain because to me the refrain is uh and
that there that the refrain has different well he calls he talks about those different moments there
are different moments of the refrain, but I would I would say you know in in the terminology that we
like this, the different styles of refraining. Um, so that some refraining is creating a territory
like a refrain is just a repetition, right? Like it's creating a territory it's creating a territory that
because you're scared and you're walking alone at night and you whistle a song and you just whistle
it over and over again because it gives you a comfort you're creating a territory. I mean that's
effectively what you're doing, but it's also and at the same time can be a way of opening out onto
uh a different kind of encounter, so that's that sense in which habit has really different uh
uh valences, um, so that that habit can be the thing which sort of normalizes routinizes and uniformizes
and it can be the thing that that leads to exactly, you know, not that at all, right? The the that it can
create back doors into other ways of living too. Like that's so perfect because there's a hinge between
those two senses. They're not just all images of each other because both of them are refraining. Both of
are are are territorializing, but that's right in the terms of creating this the space of safety we're
humming the tune over and over again, you know, sort of normalizes or habituates or calcifies, you know.
One of the important things with repetition is it's never of the same. It's never of the same thing, so
even the territorialization is a as a um a speed and intensity of of becoming, it might slow it down
it might make it feel safer, it might whatever, but the the hinge to the other one is that the only
reason that that repetition can be a a back door into creating something new is because it's
territorializing because it's gathering and organizing and creating material from which to riff on, so
yeah, it's actually, you know, it's never about calcification, not calcification, it's about
slowing down and in some ways making manageable or making differentiatable to then go somewhere else
and it's never a choice of staying here or going out, you know, it is it is incredibly dispositional of
you know, where's the what is the will that's animating it? Is it the will that wants to to stabilize it and
yet will always fail to stabilize it, or is it the will that wants to to to refine the material just enough
to make something out of it? This just makes me think of uh, this was Jeff's line years ago, and it's so
stuck with me because when I first was learning and reading Deleuze, and and he said, um, look, virtually
everybody in critical theory or in the theory world is concerned with like, given a stabilized practice
how do you change it and make it into, you know, something better, less, you know, brutal or less, you
know, uh, so so but they always start with this idea of like capitalism or patriarchy or whatever, like
these things as if they're like, you know, relatively stable entities, and and he's like, and this was his
comment, he's like, but for for folks like Deleuze, Derrida, Nietzsche, they're like how the fuck do things ever
stay together? Like it's just it's amazing that things cohere, so the so how do they cohere? How do
how are things brought to cohere? That's a completely opposite problem for most particularly like political
theory versions where they're like, given coherence, how do you change? How do you alter? How do you change
you know? And it's like the problem isn't change, the problem is stability: like how do you how do you
ever get things to repeat? Like you've told me that anecdote that um anecdote a number of times, and
every I think every other time I've heard it, I've heard it in terms of same and difference. Given
difference, how does anything stay the same? Or given sameness, how does everything change? And I hear it in
terms of identity. Yeah, and this time I didn't hear it in time in terms of identity, I heard it as
stay together or coordinate or relate to each other, and that makes it far more interesting, far less of
a paradox, is right? Given diversity, given multiplicity, how do things stay the same as and and I become
identical to each other? Well they don't and they never do. How do things you know, simple answer, how do
things coordinate and relate to each other and territorialize and de-territorialize? Well, far
easier answer, far more satisfying answer, in terms of like the simple answer is like, well they just
do things like that's the that's how multiple city works, it's just a series, it's you know, the
oneness of being is just you know, infinite self differentiation.
But the empirical question is way more interesting. Okay, now diagnose this, create a genealogy of it.
What is you know, the introduction of the horse stirrup into the war machine of the step people
and whatever, right? Yeah, how how does how does this coherence, how does this idiosyncratic singular
coherence event itself? Well and also we i i think you become more suspicious of the idea of coherence
too, where yeah like yeah, oh there's such a thing as capitalism? Really? Yeah, yeah, yeah, right, um, oh
there's such a thing? I I in fact I had this exchange coherence with unity like all up like that any kind
of coherence that's predicated on a unity? Yeah, for sure. So I had this I had this exchange with someone
on Facebook not too long ago who was saying like he said something like, you know, why you know, given that
like art and science are the the most amazing accomplishments of humanity, why are they constantly
being disparaged and having to defend themselves and and create spaces? And I was like, my I mean you
know, we've heard that line a million times, we're in freaking English department, so it's like we're
always the target, and I but for whatever reason there was just this thing that clicked to me, I was like
are they constantly being disparaged? I mean I get paid a pretty good amount of money
to like think and talk about stuff, and I know a lot of other people that do too. Like the sense of
academic freedom, I mean embattled as they are, I'm not the the claim here is not that they're not
embattled, of course, but that like the academic freedom that we have today to think, right
it's unprecedented in history, it's unprecedented in history, yeah. So this idea that there is like a
disparaging, like that there's that society is just shitting on the arts and humanities, oh it
Came out of the NEH vote, so there was a vote last week, Congress had the NEH vote to defund the NEH which
it didn't it it failed um but but regardless it came from that and I and it was just like but it
failed right like um and even if it hadn't failed there'd be other ways you just think about like the
the things that we're able to do and I'm not talking technologically I just mean like the things
that we are socially rewarded for doing never existed in history right like all three of us are getting
paid to like read stuff talk about stuff think about stuff and and to transmit that in some capacity to
future generations like that's extraordinary that's extraordinary so and that to me is one of those
examples of like to see so once you start pushing on those things you start saying like look it's easy
to say capitalism sucks and and there's part of me that just agrees with that at the same time is there
such a thing as capitalism or are there not many capitalisms that are doing many different kinds of
things in many different ways in many different places and that's then the diagnostic work of oh just
because I recognize that it's patriarchy doesn't mean that I necessarily know anything about it
yeah or that I recognize it as capitalism or that I recognize it as whatever you know normative formation
well that's one of the biggest things to work on with students is like well the answer can
always be patriarchy because patriarchy because colonization because capitalism the question is
well which one which intensity which speed what is it doing what else could it be doing which
doesn't have to be an apology for capitalism right it doesn't have to be I mean because I think a
lot of times when when people hear that kind of position this is what Zizek says about Deleuze like
Deleuze is effectively an apologist for late capitalism right and it's like well it can be but it doesn't
have to be right it's not just saying like capitalism is good which would be equally as strange because
then capitalism would have to be a thing it's still a formation right you know so it's indeterminate and
it's effects are indeterminate and and how capitalism like you said there's many different forms but it
also like Guattari's whole thing is that its structures are unconscious yeah um in ways that
you can't constitutively cannot recognize yeah right so if that indeterminacy that's not just a feature
that's fundamental to the to the system right so in that sense there's no way to to define it or tame it
with with a single categorization but yeah well yeah you you eradicate you eradicate capitalism you
eradicate human subjectivity as humans but that's where but see that's where that's why for me Nietzsche
is more important than Marx right like it's because when we diagnose these various social formations
there's a presumption of a human prior to them and like what Nietzsche gives you is and not so sure
about that human thing right like it and and that's why it's me like oh there's a normative humanness that
we all share like hold on a second and that it gets congealed into particular social formations of
wealth and and disparity and and alienation and it's like nah I'm not so sure that there's
such a thing as that human thing um I mean and or or at least another way of saying it is the whole
project here is about overcoming the human if what the human means is sort of normative categorization you
know and all that I mean it sort of depends on what you take as your markers for comparison as well
because if we're gonna think about you know the arts and sciences being under attack and you know
professor like the the academy being under attack well that that depends compared to that's right
right you know compared to other um you know other options for you know our capital deployments well
okay well that that seems pretty obviously yes but compare you know uh compared to the history of
people who tend to like think against the the herd of you know two you know for 200 years like you know
20,000 years of people who tend to to like uh make a life out of thinking against the herd yeah we're
we're about as good as it could possibly we're none of us have been you know threatened to be
you know killed for this none of us are gonna have to drink hemlock okay well yeah one of us have
only one threat right you have yeah yeah no no but when you say it that way think about it the state of
South Carolina pays a lot of people to criticize it yeah yeah right uh yeah to affect it I mean it pays
them it's structured now it's always fighting against that like there is it's it's embattled I would
never argue that but this idea that there I mean that that the notion that that's something something's
wrong there presumes a sort of purity uh some kind of historical purity that just makes it makes no
historical sense I don't even think that it makes like moral sense I don't have to pay for my
thinking by being you know a lens crafter or a bureaucrat in a law firm and you know basically
spend a good chunk of my life being okay being excommunicated from my community right right which
itself was excommunicated from Spain which itself was excommunicated right so it's I mean maybe maybe
some people just like to feel that they're under attack I mean and that that's a pretty common that's
the whole logic of opposition right absolutely I don't know if it was uh right Emerson
some some one of those old writers said like I never felt so um alive or something as when I'm in
opposition against another right so I think a lot of people yeah you just you want to you want a
common enemy or you want an enemy at least right you see this this is how social media functions
it's just so what are what are the qualities of the enemy that you pick right like what are what are the
features what's a worthy enemy what's a worthy enemy and that and that is Nietzsche's question constantly
like in Twilight of the Idols like his sort of philosophy his theory of like waging war is like
I always pick battles that I'm gonna lose right like I mean he doesn't he doesn't say that directly
because I ended up having an argument with a Nietzsche about that passage but um but but yeah like it is
this this sense of like I don't want an easy victory like I because the purpose is the agonist the
purpose is the battle in that sense so if I'm going to criticize something I want it to be worth it
right like I want it to be because there is that sense and I get that like to to uh to criticize
something is to engage with it uh it's the Eli Wiesel right like I mean it's like the ways in which
it to maintain that antagonism is to maintain its power you know one of the questions I had
because I again I was reading I've been reading that Dialogues book here and there is that Deleuze says
at one point and I couldn't tell if he's just he just means this in a casual interpersonal sense like
in conversation or if he means it for scholarship but he says that anytime somebody poses an objection to me
I immediately want to just go on to a different get out of there like I have no answer I have no response
and I I understand that in in terms of conversation because I do that all the time
like if somebody objects to me like yeah okay cool like I'm just like yeah you're right I don't
whatever you know but but in your writing I don't always do that and I don't think Deleuze always
does that right I mean like he objects to plenty of stuff yeah and it's right I mean he was talking
about conversations in that passage and he says because getting out that never happens that way
becoming doesn't happen that way it doesn't happen in the direct confrontation between different
positions right so what happens in the direct confrontation between different positions is that we both
solidify and and and stabilize our relative positionality the the becoming in which he's
interested is always happening he says behind your back like behind your back when when you're in the when
you think you're in the midst of this you know me versus but isn't it but yeah isn't that the best place
behind your back because i i i love playing devil's advocate and i and i love sort of i i love it when i find the
worthy enemy that attacks my position and partially because it it rouses me to giving the best possible
defense of it and I really believe in it at the moment and you know it's like maybe not 10 out of 10
times but I don't know nine eight out of 10 times it's like a bit after that it's like oh I'm able to
see my position a little bit differently and I think I've got to change it this is not necessarily
to what the other person said but something about it was revealed to me and it was only because
you know the force with which I had to crystallize it clarify yeah this is why I've I mean I I say this
in grad classes all the time I I think the biggest intellectual danger is straw manning um and and that can
come from selecting an object that's just not very smart or very supple like you know there are plenty
of things that are themselves straw man's straw man and then there's this capitalism patriarchy right
whatever whatever it may be or even just you know a critic that you're reading that you want to
distinguish your reading of Faulkner from right like that um and it's we do it all I I see myself do it
all of the time uh where I like oh well I'm kind of oversimplifying this position a little bit what
happens if I don't oversimplify that position then I don't have a distinctive position in response to
it that's when things get interesting to me that's when things get interesting but they're hard and
messy because then you end up saying like it's not that I agree or disagree with you know so and so
it's that I don't really know what my relationship is and I don't even know that there's a me and a
broad and then we have a relationship like as if there's two distinctive things there are just
different sort of conjunctions of it but uh but that's really hard to at least for me that's not
Instinctive, like I, I've had to learn that. I've had to learn it's work, I think I've gotten better at
that really just over the last year or two, maybe. Yeah, just pretty recently because, um, I find myself
doing that in class with texts that I think if I had read three years ago I would have simply
rejected but because I'm performing this sort of generous interpretation, I end up, you end up
incorporating your own reaction. Yeah, and diagnosing your own reaction and then you see them as an effect
of something that's right, so then you're just, that just seeing somebody as an effect of something.
It kind of lends itself to a more generous, I think that is the strongest sense in which, you know, teaching
is the best way to learn is because I always hated classes where we were, uh, um, you know, we were reading
something that the professor didn't like and it was kind of obvious and it was really hard to get your
hooks into it, so I just, I didn't want to do that. Yeah, obviously, you know, from time to time I'm reading
texts that I, you know, historically have some kind of allergy to or something. It's like I don't, I don't
like it at first and, um, and I have, you know, you have to sort of change your orientation. I'm not gonna
let my students, you know, do this and, um, and then they're almost always the best ones to teach because
you have to give them, you, you have to put so much more work and thought and attention into making
them interesting and then they become interesting and they become interesting. Like this is the
beautiful thing, like in the first aphorism, like I want to see, uh, yeah, I want to see beauty and
what's necessary and things, but what you find because I like when I whenever I teach how Harold Bloom
the, um, in my undergrad literary, the literary theory class, you know, he's old school and everybody hates
him. It's super easy, it's super easy to hate him, right? Like if you have any di bone in your body you're
just like, um, so I always have to come in as the sort of like defender of Bloom and over the years I'm
like, I think he's got some really genuinely sincerely important points, uh, worth making. I don't, there's
a lot of things that I don't agree with that I can still, but I'm like I can offer the arguments and I
can, you know, that that are going to make you guys question your self-righteousness, um, and, and that's the
more important thing. It's like if you leave this because they all come into class knowing that Harold
Bloom is a douche, you know, that's just, that's just the response that they have and then but they
leave the class going like I don't know if I hate Harold Bloom or not. I'm like, okay, yeah, now, now there's
something to be to be done with it, right? Right? I can only think of one prominent example where I just
couldn't do it no matter how hard I tried and that was when I was teaching social cognitivism like, um
flowers and a bunch of haze, yeah, and I just, you know, I could do it with I could do it with Peter Elbow
I could do it with, you know, like I mean a bunch of these people I could do it with even though, like
you know, I still had I still wanted to make tweaks or little things, but I could really throw myself into
it by the social cognitivist man I just in fact I came out of that liking them even less. Yeah,
Habermas has always been my limit case where I'm just like, yeah, I can't generously I just can't
generously read this and maybe someday but, yeah, I just my students like I'll occasionally assign
something that they all hate but I have a bad predictive like I don't necessarily know that they're
they're all going to hate it or at least that so but then they decide that they hate it and so that
kind of establishes the tone of the class and I find myself I don't I don't enjoy that. I don't enjoy
hate reading stuff anymore. It's just not the way that I orient myself towards the stuff that I assign
I wouldn't have assigned it if I hated it or sometimes I'm just I didn't read all of it. Yeah, and then
I've already assigned it or sometimes I assign stuff I mean like, you know, I don't obviously do this
with every or even most of my assignments but sometimes this is like I just close my eyes and
point to something I'm like I'm going to teach that. I mean it fits for a handful of reasons but I've
never really read it before I don't have a good reason for including it. It's now just there to throw
a little bit of a wrench into, you know, whenever I teach a class there's a there's a kind of a story
that I'm telling there's like or a repetition of a question that I'm dealing with and sometimes the
best ways of of doing that is to throw in a wild card. Me like I have no idea if this is going to
do you speak to it at all and almost every time I think this is largely again because of what we said
in that aphorism because it requires so much work in in going into it it says some of the most
interesting things about you know the narrative or or uh question that I want to deal with
because you don't have your line prepared right? Like this you don't already know when you open the page
What you're getting in ways that we we just do I mean if you know we've been around this industry
for a little while it's like okay we know something about before we pick up a book we know something
about like the the theoretical itinerary or who recommended it to us or you know just whatever you
and usually pretty you know surprisingly accurately even if you've never read it you can place it very
well yeah yeah and it's not it's nice to encounter those those unplaceable things or or things that
don't fit as fit as easily or to force you to engage like if you have to teach something like that and
then you have to deal with the complexity because you know oftentimes that they're going to come in and
you know it doesn't even matter whether they all hate it or all love it or half and half it's still
it's all going to be love and hate there's not going to be engagement and you know that right so
it's like okay right I wanted what I want to teach is an immersion in complexity and that means
love and hate are kind of out the window yeah you know back doors that's what you're looking for
yeah yeah yeah yeah I end up kind of I don't know if empathizing is what I end up empathizing a little
bit more with the supposed faults of certain writers like and I'm not sure why that happens like this but
in the past I would have yeah like again I would have just simply rejected it but now I like when
they make like if you make a claim that's not you know fully articulated or you don't contextualize
something well enough in an essay I end up seeing that as like they you know I'm like they try like
I I kind of see it as like a necessary blind spot for them or it's like it's not something that
if you critiqued it that they would somehow be able to fix it's just like this is how they present
right they're not wrong it's it's the idea that nobody is nobody is precisely wrong right everybody is a
symptom of a problem and if you if you closed off every line of potential attack you it would you
never stop writing it would be impenetrable nothing would move well so and and in many ways I think
that's like often well um when I used to be a a good teacher and I had like a series of questions like
for each of the theory essays for grad theory classes for each of the essays I had them go through a
series and respond to a series of questions and question number five or something was like
what criticisms or what critiques do you have to offer to this thing like what's wrong with it you
know what are some obviously wrong things and then the next question and this was the important one
was imagine that the writer had thought about those things and felt that they had responded to
them in the essay what are the ways that they did that right imagine if Foucault didn't you know like
knew that homosexuality existed before 1860 right or or whatever right that like you they're like
well that's so stupid no homosexuality was invented in 1860 that's ridiculous it's like okay imagine for
a second that Foucault knew that and what is he doing now and if you do that like I mean that to me was
that that was a sort of a method for producing that kind of generous engagement is imagine that the
the thinker that you're reading had anticipated already anticipated your objection and your resistance
and your even distaste and did it anyway right like why why did they do that right like what was what's
going on you know so I mean look these folks are smart but but that's the Nietzschean line right like
like these are expressions of ways of life like they're just they're different styles of life right
so this is some of the best writing advice I think I've ever gotten here from well from anyone but
from Nietzsche and 282 on on gate there are certain tricks of the spirit by which even great minds betray
that they come from the mob or half mob the gate and stride of their thoughts especially plays the
traitor uh plays the traitor they cannot walk thus Napoleon too who's usually like his poster boy for
everything amazing uh thus Napoleon too was unable in his great vexation to walk in a princely and
legitimate fashion on occasions that really demanded it such as the great coronation processions even there
he was always just the leader of a column proud and hasty at the same time and very conscious of it it is
laughable to behold those authors who make the ruffled robes of lawn sentences rustle about themselves
they are trying to hide their feet I I feel like in I tell my students this pretty frequently if there's one
thing that I am really doing for them it is that I am teaching or installing a speed of their thinking and
writing that I am slowing things down for them and getting them used to used to slowing things down
in terms of both their their reading and their writing and largely you know I usually justify
like look at that because there's something wrong with going faster because there's you know um or
going with greater breadth it's just because that's what you generally that's you're very well
Practiced practice on that, and that's what most courses do, and you'll get that practice. It's good
practice and you get lots of it. Just very rarely get the opportunity to do it differently. And but I also
really realized, I think it's because I I need that injection of of um slowness in my own thinking that
I'm so um I can see the thing. I can see the hook and you know this, the conversation that we're having
earlier about Nate, your sort of um antagonism in in writing, like you find the thing, the blind spot that
they had and then you latch on to it and I I know that feeling. It's like it's not just that I find
that blind spot or that mistake that they made but then it becomes the hinge point of my entire argument
around them and I and I need it and then when I start to spend more time with it and that blind spot
becomes less important or it goes away entirely, it's like there's a moment of crisis always that
it's like now I've lost the reason you know the reason that of reading this person like holy
shit what an asshole I am, but the only person I am reading this person is I found a bullseye on their
on their forehead and now I've invested all this time I've got to do something else with it. It's usually
that's like the clearing that I need to do something more interesting, but I just like I love the idea
of a gate of thought. Yeah, yeah, and I would you know I think this is what I really like about
writing is that writing yeah is is an interjection of speed into thinking. It it can it can modulate the
gate and thoughts. Yeah, yeah, right. It's it's a little more I mean for me it's it's a little more
rare to have like breakthroughs in conversation. I mean it can happen while teaching or during this
podcast. You can say something that you genuinely have never thought before like, but it's it's more
it's kind of conversations are a little too quick for me at least to to do the same kind of work
that you would do in your writing. Yeah, I mean you're just not like you're saying like the fact
just the medium of it, the fact that you can go back and revise, right? The fact that it's not
everything's vanishing in a conversation constantly like we said something it's gone, like I mean it's
sort of it's in the ether. We can go back and listen to it later but even that like temporally that takes
a lot of work like we were talking about with you trying to teach tv like it's just like there's a
different speed to that. Yeah then than with writing. Yeah but it's interesting I find conversations slower
than writing for me and I don't think this is a good thing for me with conversation I usually do
have my breakthroughs in conversation because I have to shut up and listen to somebody for a little
bit and then I'm so active and then I have to sit on what I was gonna say and whatever I'm thinking
about is being sort of poked and prodded at by whoever's talking at the time and so I do come
up with my breakthroughs there and then what I discover when I'm writing my natural proclivity
is to just get it all down and it comes out really fast and really condensed and there's nothing slowing
it down and you know I think it's only recently that I've figured out how to modulate my writing
to actually do the work of not just you know getting the you know the fully the idea up here
out on the page but like really just see the writing process as you know the the um as the
process as the thinking process. It's right that I've been saying that's my you know teaching philosophy
for like years. It's largely I I say that because it's like what I need the most. I I think I'm more
like you boo boo in that regard because I I feel like in conversation for the most part
it's hard not to just take a position um and I feel like in writing it's much easier for me not
to take a position and to just sort of to write through I mean that's most of the writing that I
do is I'm just writing through something that I've read, trying to sort of get its sense, trying to like
what's it where is it coming from um whereas in a conversation I feel like I need to have an opinion
like I need to have a uh you know like I've got to and it's partly my personality right? like I've
got to be able to say you know I think this and I like this and I don't like that and so
uh um and but I but I I don't really like that about my conversational style. It's and so as you
guys know like I often will overly polemicize it just to ridicule just to the point of absurdity
where I'm just going to like amplify that um and that's a way of making it comical and allowing me
not to believe in the positions that I'm taking in a conversation because writing for me is much
much more of a much more careful um and much more precise and you know it it slows it just slows me
down. Well there's also I mean not all the time but there's there's stuff that's interesting in
writing that is not interesting in conversation like because of the speed because it's like if
You're if you're doing a real close reading of a text and you're dealing with like the syntax and
etymology and all this fucking shit you would never bring, I mean you could try to bring it up in class
but it's like everyone's be like what's happening like we need like kind of you need like chunks
and you need uh like little um like just slogans almost yeah and and teaching it makes me it makes
me think of i you know and it's just been so long ago but when i took John Salas's class on Hegel
The Phenomenology of Spirit and we spent the entire semester on the prelude like we never got to the
book um and so we so we repeated that class for you with the Hegel yeah yeah yeah I mean it was it was
extraordinary because it was like every sentence every phrase every word we were spinning off you
know right um and it was it was meticulous now I don't know that I was ready for it well I i know
that i wasn't ready for it I wasn't up to speed to be able to do that kind of slowness um but it was
still interesting that it was still interesting and i feel like for instance the dare not class
like i i when i taught that two years ago or what i'm going to do it again in the spring um we do
work through the text more than i do in most cases you know um and so there is that kind of
slowing down so and that's that feels more to me like like writing uh that's how it's most of my
classes it's that maybe that's why i like the conversation because it's so it's it's so textually
focused and i think you know too of you know um maybe because the things that's the
graduate experiences that some that stick out in my head the most i think are the the reading groups
that we had too where you know what we would go through we went through The Logic of Sense and
differance and badu and you know yeah those were incredibly slow but this is all the everybody sort of
has the same expectations in those groups right at least maybe this is an insecurity of mine but i feel
like i have i still feel like i have to entertain some of my like especially my first year students
like i have to do something where it's not just running the close reading machine which i'm happy to do
and i think is is fun but i i tend to like i have a shit ton of notes and then i just try not to
even look at them basically for some of these classes whereas if i did look at them sometimes
like i'm missing so much interesting stuff that i could have talked about yeah um so i'm not saying
it's the right way to do it it's just what i tend to do well because because i with my first year
students i lean into it even more because i feel like i'm teaching them to do the the close reading
stuff like they're not used to at all really engaging with the text and i can actually allow for more
flexibility and freedom with my upper year students now what i don't do though and i noticed that this
paralyzes me is if i have all of the notes and if i have like if there's anything in the text that i
want to get to it's almost always a disservice to students because i have to bully our our way through
there and i've become a much better teacher once i learned how to um uh get at their level and speed and
then and and and prompt them to read through the text and then allow them to develop and the only
thing you know my corrective is never at the level of content my intervention is always at the level of
okay well where where are you thinking let's get everyone to the page that you're looking at let's
think through that does that you know and then we'll talk about that line or sentence or paragraph for
a little bit and then it'll make someone else think of another paragraph somewhere else and that'll
take us there and so the only intervention that i'm making is like whatever conversation we're having
this is how it's going to be generated but the conversation will go wherever we take it so
that's like what we do yeah yeah it is largely what we do yeah it's just that i have to like you know
know sort of be the i have to be like right right right you can't rely on right right right I like to
have can i mean i like to have control over the the discussion i i mean i used to like i used to need
it sometimes when like i had a i had a discussion on thursday where i let them lead and i rarely do
that and i just because they were very it was almost like i didn't have a choice like where everybody's
raising their hand all at once so i'm like you then you then you and so i'm just like i kind of
let it happen because i was like whatever but i found myself not enjoying it like i was just kind
of like because i i mean this is going to sound really not but i'm like i have stuff to say that's
potentially more compelling than what everybody's saying yeah right right I mean so i i found myself
thinking like all right next class that's not what's going to happen the the balance is so delicate
because it can so easily they can so easily like rampage you know like a herd of you know antelope
and it's just like they are dispersed and they just all go everywhere and that's not fun that's
not student-led conversation like student well that is student-led conversation right like you know
i'm it's i'm i'm allowing the students interest and curiosity to um go through the text but i also
think and here's you know here's my power control trip i don't think that they know how to follow
their curiosity i don't think they know what curiosity is i have to constantly i'm constantly
giving them the parameters and the constraints of figuring out what is curious and interesting to
them mm-hmm mm-hmm i do think there's also a value i mean this is a contra uh because i tend to do the
same thing i remember uh my second year teaching here in the grad class and i was like well i'm going to
make this a discussion class and that lasted like two weeks and i'm like okay i'm just going to go
back because you guys have taken classes with me i don't it's not a discussion class it's a lecture
and it's an interactive lecture people can jump in but it's a lecture like that's how i that's just how
i teach um grad grad classes particularly um but i do feel like a particular i mean especially with
undergrads at least to me it's really useful to let them talk things out like um not because of the
content of what they're saying right like the content of what they're saying is often quite banal
um and even what they're saying about the text that you're engaged is oftentimes quite banal but
to talk it to talk it through and then you can challenge them on a point or have somebody else
in the class challenge them on a point and having to articulate and then respond that that's really
where where the so even if the content of the positions that they're taking are kind of
not as sophisticated as the one that you would give them if you just let it if you just led it not
let it but if you if you led the interaction uh oftentimes i i feel like my best classes are
ones where i i allow them to work through the thing and i steer it indirectly meaning i i don't say
i don't say i i'll i sometimes they'll do this thing like well now what if we bring in Rebecca's
point here yeah uh and then i will and then i will re-articulate Rebecca's point to be something
completely just a little bit yeah it's sad but it's a really smart thing that Rebecca said and
Rebecca's like what exactly Rebecca's like i said that i'm smart wow damn all right so but it is but
i i like the way that you talked about it for it's it's very it isn't it does feel like a delicate
procedure like when when when i'm on it when it's clicking i feel like i've you know i i've got all
these strings and i'm connecting them and they're going and everything but then oftentimes it's you
know i don't it's like it's clunky and i'm like yeah yeah because it's very kind of most of what we
do is on the whiteboard and what i do is i take those strings like i take the what my students say and
then i'll do that little re-articulating thing and i'll write it on the board and then we'll create
lines we'll create little temporary categories and columns and they'll get reconfigured and i
like i articulate the board as our public communal thinking space and that once whatever you say is on
the board it's not yours anymore it's the classes and that it's subject to experimentation so it doesn't
sit there as you know it's not anyone's property it's it's there as raw material to work with and
which is why i can let things sit even when they look stupid or banal or completely opposed to the
text and my goal isn't i don't i don't challenge what they say and i don't have each other challenge i
have them push through it like all right now you articulate it this way is anyone are there a text or
passages that might engage this and then you let it sit for long enough and then eventually someone's
you know shifting it reverse sometimes you're just like reversing it's like holy
shit the thing that i thought he was saying was the exact opposite but it just took like four
different people engaging it to figure that out i i think you could also um you could map on the
kind of ontological coordinates of either Deleuze or Nietzsche onto the classroom maybe in a productive
way where you like you were just talking the delicate balance that made me think of it in these terms
um where it's like for for a class for a class to be functioning well for me or the way that
all of us were describing i think is where you are both you're simultaneously vulnerable or open to
difference open to those relations but also you're making creative cuts yeah right and closures right
so difference in identity vulnerability closure that kind of you're right in the middle of that somehow
or you're just kind of you're oscillating yeah between the two and when it's clunky is when it gets too
much too far yeah yeah in in one direction i think that's right
you